[Music]
there is no help for him in god
but thou o lord at a shield for me
my glory
and the lifter up of my head
i cried unto the lord with my voice
and he heard me
out of his holy hill
i laid me down and slept
i wait
for the lord sustained me
i will not be afraid of ten thousands of
people that have set themselves against
me round about
arise o lord save me o my god
for thou has smitten all my enemies upon
the cheekbone thou hast broken the teeth
of the ungodly
salvation belongeth unto the lord
thy blessing
is upon thy people
god is good
and all the time
[Music]
that was psalm 3 a very beautiful psalm
nothing i say in this presentation will
be symbolic
if it is i'll forewarn you
if i don't warn you then everything i
get tell you will be
literal by the way the bible is
overwhelmingly
literal
it is overwhelmingly
literal though on the otherwise says
take it as it reads
unless it is obviously symbolic like and
i stood up on the sand of the sea and
saw this rise up out of the sea having
seven heads and ten horns well clearly
that is symbolic but overwhelmingly the
bible is literal now let's read some
literal passages
let's go to psalm 24.
when's our next session 11 o'clock
11 30. i thought it was 11.
all right
i must be seeing incorrectly
what book did i say
listen again what book did i say
okay what chapter
one verse
one
i didn't give it i'm giving it now one
when you found it say amen amen
now remember most of the bible is what
now read with that in mind also when
reading the bible read the words as if
god is speaking to you
let me say it again even though you may
be reading the words let your voice be
the voice of god speaking his words to
you
let's read the earth is the lord's and
the fullness thereof the world and they
that dwelt therein stop
let us
dissect that verse as we read
microscopically
the earth
is the lord's
why
because he made it now creation
is the basis of ownership
if you can prove you created something
then you want it yeah
all right
the earth
is the lord keep reading
no no keep reading no no it's not verse
two we're reading verse one again the
earth is the lord's come on and the
fullness thereof stop what's the
fullness
give me some examples of all that's in
it because you're right but let's
itemize
people
animals well the verses and the world
and fear that where they're in yes
animals
the water the vegetation the fauna the
flora if you're scientific in mind
who's from south africa
the gold
who's from zambia
the copper
who's from botswana
the diamonds
who's from saudi arabia
the oil the earth sit with me is the
lord stop that's literal
it's not yours
don't pollute it
and the fullness thereof
the world and they that dwell therein
now you and i at a certain level belong
to god
why by virtue of creation
now by virtue of our choice we give
ourselves a savior
let me say it again by virtue of our
choice
we give ourselves to satan
also writes in testimonies volume 1 page
341 paragraph 1 fallen man is satan's
lawful captive
but understand that you and i belong to
god
let's go to first corinthians 6.
we read from verse 19.
first corinthians 6
reading from verse 19
all right there are some
nice people still trying to find it
i can hear the pages turning and that's
good no it's a good sound to hear in
god's house
the sound of the bible pages all right
are you there now
read with me what does it say what
knowing not what that your body is the
temple of the
which is
which you have of
and ye
are not your own stop
now let's get ridiculous
who owns this arm
why did you hesitate
okay because you don't want to talk
about my arm okay your arm who owns your
right arm
god
not the health system of the united
kingdom god
who owns your sight oh god
who owns your mental capacity to pursue
that degree god this is literal
the ease with which you master music and
play the piano so skillfully and
effortlessly that endowment belongs to
god
amen
when we understand that our chest will
come down
are you amen me
so you're playing with the london
philharmonic no no that belongs to god
for you not your own keep reading
for er
box come on with a price stop
what's the price
the blood of christ
therefore there is a verse
glorify god
in your body
and in your spirit
which are gods
now
how can we glorify god
in our body
now this is what i wanted to tell the
young people but i'll assume all of you
are young so this is still a youth
presentation how can we glorify god in
our body
by what we eat
what we see by what we look at because
it affects us
but what we listen to by how we
dress if i truly accept this body
doesn't belong to me i cannot use it for
fornication
can you just turn me off
is this mic working
can you hear me
if this now let me ask you this if you
borrowed my car
to run to the supermarket
would you use it to transport cocaine
no no
that's not your car
now can i use this
for fornication no why it belongs to god
let me get my own body that i make
this belongs to god
can i paint it
no
if you borrowed my car and it's black
can you paint it polka dot no
why
it's not yours
to whom do your fingernails belong
now you're hesitating
i told you the bible is overwhelmingly
who owns your fingernails
did he tell you paint them
[Music]
who owns your ear
can he tell you to borrow a hole in it
to add to the one he gave you naturally
um
you're looking at ms do i need
medication
i don't need medication the bible must
be taken as it reads
now when young men and young women
listen to ellen white
historical sketches page 285 paragraph
four
i'm waiting
for you to tell me what i just said
all right here's what it says
every youth
should be impressed with the fact
that he's not his own
that his time his strength
his time his talents belong to god
because god can take him
to remind you it's his
you know young people seem to think
sickness is for all people
and paralysis is for all people
and wheelchairs are for old people
listen to me you're wrong
i came in from new york to manchester
on the flight was a boy about 14 years
old blind we could stick
when i saw him my heart broke i said
father so young let him see the world
blind someone was leading him 14 15
that's how old you look
all that you have
belongs to god
and was given to you and to me
for one major reason what's that
to glorify god what's the second reason
to bless mankind
let me say it again
everything you and i have our faculties
our body our health our possessions are
given to us or entrusted to us by god
for two reasons god's glory and the
blessing of mankind there isn't a third
so the earth is the lord's and the
fullness thereof the world and they that
dwell therein what else belongs to god
as we become more extreme the bible is
an extreme book
you see if god is light and sadness
darkness there are two extremes
go to first chronicles 29
first chronicles 29
we read from verse 11.
first chronicles 29 a reading from verse
11.
when you found it say man
if you're still looking say man
amen all right thank you for being
honest but hurry up
right you have it now first chronicles
29 reading from verse 11.
are you there now
read with me thine oh lord is the
greatness and the power and the glory
and the victory and the majesty stop
that's a list of five things
that come from god
what's the first one
great name some great people
that are alive today great people
who
bill gates yes okay bill gates very
influential this and his wealth
and what he did with whatever his
microsoft company whatever it was yes
bill gates okay anybody else
elizabeth is a great person
my wife and i were talking and she said
when people say the queen they'll
automatically think of elizabeth even
though they're other countries with
queens
are you with me but when you say the
queen no one thinks of the queen of
denmark or neverland they think of
elizabeth
that's great
when she dies every head of state will
be in london
that's greatness that comes from god
god allows some people to be great that
they might use that greatness
to glorify him and to benefit others
thine oh lord is the greatness what's
the next word
the power name some powerful people not
ceremonially powerful i
yes i mean he commands the most powerful
army on the face of the earth
but he was gift now by the way he was
given that by god
listen to what daniel told
nebuchadnezzar
thou king are the king of kings
for the god of heaven had given thee a
kingdom
power
and strength and glory and wheresoever
the children of men dwell the beasts of
the field and the fouls of the heaven
have he given into thy hand and have
made the ruler over them all god gave
that kingdom to nebuchadnezzar
by the way god told jeremiah tell the
israelites to submit
yes
no protest
not protest the government god told
jeremiah tell the israelites submit and
live a quiet life
so they don't bring problems on
themselves
[Music]
then you end up in jail i want the
church to pray
leave the government alone criticize the
church
don't attack it
christ never criticized the roman
government
but he criticized the church
and so god gave nebuchadnezzar that
kingdom god gave judah to nebuchadnezzar
daniel 1 1 2.
and so thine oh lord is the greatness
and the power and the glory
what's glory
in a human
context man
no in a human context a secular context
because non-believers have glory
the bling bling okay
never seen that in the bible bling bling
okay
okay all right what's glory who has
glory
all right okay success okay okay
who won the who won the i don't follow
it but uh who won the uh uefa cup
now you people no tell me
well whoever arsenal okay that's glory
well whoever that's glory
who won the
nfl world cup that's glory
thy lord is the greatness
and the power
and the glory and the victory
have you won something
have you conquered something
god allowed him
daniel 2 21 he removeth kings and
sentence of kings i'm trying to tell
everything comes from god
and the majesty
keep reading verse 11 of first
chronicles 29
die in the lord is the greatest the
power of the glory the victory the
majesty for all that is where
in the heavens stop what's in the heaven
come on what's in the heavens
stars come on planets uh-huh everything
in heaven is thine
for all that is in the heaven and in the
earth is
thine
oh lord is the kingdom and thou art
exalted as head above all read verse 12
now both
riches come on and honor cometh this
love who has honor on earth think of
someone with honor the person's
respected and revealed honor
the pope
that's on him
the dalai lama
honor
there are some people based on their
position
no matter who you are you just respect
them
if mother teresa were alive
honor
any adventists on that list okay it is
so honored are you with me
that comes from god
both riches on honor come away and are
exalted outrageous overall
in thine hand is power and might
power
mind and in that hand it is to make
great and to give strength unto all
now let's skip 13 go to 14 read 14 for
me now
but who am i
who's speaking
david
what's his position
king
but here's what he says but who am i
and what is my people that we should be
able to offer so willingly after this
sort keep reading for all things come of
thee
and if i know
have we given thee now this is supposed
to be youth session now let me see who
which one of you is thinking
what is it that also comes from god
okay wisdom yes but remember it's youth
session
youth
you're young
you're strong
you're energetic
that comes from god
it won't last forever
you'll get to my stage
are you listening to me now that you
have it what are you going to do
run around the village trying to be the
village ram or village stud no it's
given to us by god
for his glory
so that there are people alive today who
can say i know three young men who are
just like daniel and anaya mishael
azariah amen
upright young men are not just in the
bible i know some
and they're from manchester
and birmingham
and swansea
and bologna
and nairobi
cardiff
and barbados
and kenya aware of jamaica
and lithuania
and uk wherever i know some upright
young people
who jumped out of the pages of the bible
and they are alive today thank you
youth
is a gift from god there's a famous
irish playwright named oscar wilde
he said youth is wasted on the young and
he was right
to a large degree
but god's arrangement is he's given us
youth or you youth that it might be used
for his glory so he gives strength to
the youth and wisdom to the aged that we
might work
together amen
there's something else god gives to us
you think of honor
when someone has honor what does that
person also have in great abundance it
starts with an eye
influence
now
influence is something you cannot stop
the moment someone walks in the person
influences those watching him or her by
the way you dressed where you walk the
way you conduct yourself you influence
people whether you plan to or not all
you and i can do is decide whether it
will be negative
or possible that's the limit of our
control but no one can shut off into
even dead people have influence
listen to the bible
by faith able often unto god a more
excellent sacrifice than cain by which
he obtained witness that he was
righteous god testifying of his gifts
and by eight he being dead
yet speaking of
there are germans today still admiring
hitler and trying to carry on his legacy
when i go to uganda there are people who
miss idiamin
[Music]
dead but exerting an influence
influence
hello i writes
that god holds us responsible
for the influence we exert over others
you see when god made the world he made
to adults
we look at the gift of influence which
belongs to god he entrusts it to us god
could have made eight billion adults
listen to me carefully
he may too
so that everyone born into the world
would be subject to the influence of
somebody else
when you raise your child in your home
in the church
in the school that child is bombarded
by
influence and so he wants to be like the
teacher
or like cristiano ronaldo or like you
know david cameron or she like theresa
may or whomever because influence does
that to us now god tells his people now
exert the kind of influence that leads a
person to say i'd like to be like jesus
[Music]
and so there's a great burden of the
young
you know christ was 17.
christ was 18.
he was 19. he was 14. he was 13.
he was two
he was 31
which means christ was an example to us
in infancy
adolescence
youth and adulthood
the same person
my brothers and sisters
some of you are in college who's in
college race you have
no one in college
what do you study
what's that
mechanical engineering okay very good my
sister did you raise your hand
what are you studying
what's that
[Music]
caring for somebody who needs it all
right now question for you why are you
studying mechanical engineering
you're interested in motion
all right why are you studying care
you like to care for people anybody else
studying anything else
yes what are you studying
why
and he likes motion
all right
did i see another handle what are you
studying
what adult adult nursing sounds like
care okay
why
to gain the knowledge
why are you pointing at her
medical minister okay anybody else
studying anything
let's say you graduated from college
you've already finished what did you
study
what did you study
physical therapy why
you want to use your hands
okay but you can use your hands and
be a carpenter why physical therapy
health-wise okay what do you business
studies why uh to gain knowledge
of operating business okay that's fine
nothing illegal about that
now
let's go to first corinthians 10 31.
actually you shouldn't have to go there
you should just say
whether therefore come on
eat or drink stop or study adult care
or study mechanical engineering
or study
business or study physical therapy or
study adult whatever finish the verse
now do all to the glory of god
why because the capacity that allows you
to study the complexity of mechanical
engineering
comes from god
the ability you had to study physical
therapy and to understand how the
shoulder works
and what causes impingement
and winging of the scapula
and a cathodic posture and a forward
head posture all of that comes from god
in business
from god
which means that when i ask you why you
should have said because i can use it
for the glory of god
if you look at the ten commandments
by the way
listen to this quotation from ellen
white listen carefully and then tell me
in your own words what it means in one
short sentence are you listening
let's pray first father as i continue to
speak to those whom you love so much
give me simple expression dear god
and let me as i speak seek your glory
in jesus name i pray amen listen
carefully to what elohit writes
there is nothing save the selfish heart
of man
that lives into itself
no bird that cleaves the air
no animal that moves upon the ground but
ministers to some other life
there is no leaf of the forest or lowly
blade of grass but has its ministry
every tree and shrub and leaf pours
forth that element of life without which
neither man nor animal could live
and man an animal in turn ministered to
the life of tree and shrub and leaf
the flowers breathe fragrance and unfold
the beauty and blessing to the world
the sun sheds its light to gladden a
thousand worlds
the ocean itself the source of all our
springs and fountains receives the
strains from every land
but takes to give the mists ascending
from its bosom fall in showers to water
the earth
that it may bring forth
and bud
the desire of ages page 20
paragraph two
in one sentence what is that paragraph
saying
symbiotic okay
all god's creation serves
all creation
has as its purpose service to something
else except man now let me revise that
god gave man that purpose but sin ruined
it
let me say it more simply
mankind is the only aspect of creation
that serves itself
which means you and i were put on this
earth for two reasons name them
the glory of god and the blessing of
others that's it
now that is extreme
and that does not fit the carnal mind
the carnal mind says i was put on the
earth for two reasons three me
myself
now look at the ten commandments
commandment one what does that say
that describes the relationship between
you and god that's vertical commandment
come on say it start again because
you're saying it for god
or any likeness of anything that is in
heaven above or that is in the earth
beneath all that is in the water under
the earth thou shalt not bow down
thyself to them nor serve them come on
for i the lord thy god i'm a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
ensuring mercy unto thousands of them
that love me and keep my commandments
that's between you and god vertical
commandment 3 say
thou shalt not take the name of the lord
thy god in vain for the lord will not
hold him guiltless that taketh his name
in vain again you and god
now no one should stumble on commandment
4.
say it with me remember the sabbath day
to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the sabbath
of the lord thy god in it thou shalt not
do any work thou not thy son nor thy
daughter thy man's servant not i made
servant not thy cattle nor thy stranger
that is within thy gate for in six days
the lord made heaven and earth the sea
and all that in them is and rested
seventh day wherefore the lord blessed
the sabbath day and hallowed you and god
keeping his name
commandment five
honor thy father and thy mother that thy
days may be long upon the land which the
lord thy god giveth thee now that's
horizontal
you and somebody else on the earth
commandant six thou shalt not kill or
resemble commandment seven thou shalt
not commit adultery that's you and
somebody else commandment eight thou
shalt not steal same thing commandment
nine thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor ten thou shalt not
covet thy neighbor's house thou shalt
not covet thy neighbor's wife nor his
manservant noise made servant noise ox
noise ass no anything that is thy
neighbor stop
the commandments point our duties in two
directions name them
to god
and our fellow man nothing to us
that is extreme
it's also literal
nothing
to us
so i wanted my young brothers and
sisters to understand
contrary to the doctrines of this world
your purpose in this life
is twofold
glorify god
and be a blessing to your fellow man
now someone said to me once a friend of
mine in canada when do i express myself
my answer was
never
never unless you rewrite genesis 1 26
and god said let us make man in our
image and man's image
let us make man in our image case closed
everything he does
should have reflected
god
in other words before sin adam had no
image of his own
if he never sinned
his children would not have had his
image they would have had god's images
let me hammer it again
into your consciousness
you and i
are put on this earth
they glorify god and be a blessing to
others now this must be the foundation
of any decision you're making
to avoid long-term catastrophe
you must ask two questions now you're
considering moving from london
to inverness
what do you ask
how will this glorify and you must try
to figure out how
[Music]
you literally sit down and write here
are the benefits for the work for the
gospel for god now how will others
benefit you think.
[Music]
then you say father
i have fought i've reached the limits
now what do you think the bible says
trust in the lord with all thy heart and
lean not unto thy born understanding it
did not say don't use your understanding
it says don't lean on
so you use it then you present your
findings to god
you're in love with a young man or a
young woman
what's the first question
how does this glorify god
don't tell me all your girlfriends have
a man and you need one how will this
glorify god
that was the second question
how will others be blessed
you want a child
which woman doesn't
what's the first question you ask
how will this because i wish hitler's
mother had never had him
are you listening to me
and lenin
who killed all these millions and stalin
and paul park who destroyed one-third of
the population of cambodia in the early
70s i wish they'd never been born
when the angel gabriel told john the
baptist's father to be he'd have a son
he said and thou shalt have gladness and
many shall rejoice at his birth
you bring a child into the world people
should be blessed by that child
amen are you with me and so you ask how
will this glorify god how will maybe you
already have two you want the third
what's the question
when you're laughing at me it's okay
what's in this for god
i can't say well my tribe usually has
five.
i was in scotland a few years ago
and this man came with his wife and
children counseling six children
and having financial problems
most people with sick children have
financial problems
so i said to him why do you have six
children
i like children
okay that's not against the law of
england as far as i know the uk i like
children
i said well well yes but
did god tell you have six
he looked at me
i said did you ask god should i have six
he just looked at me
he kept looking at me because he just
wanted six
any financial problem
i was in tanzania
i'm talking about asking god the glory
of god first
this couple came to me young man young
nice handsome couple
what's the problem
we want a child
i say why
no i said
how long have you been married nine
months
nine months i said do you know how many
couples would be happy to say we have no
child after nine months so the church
doesn't have to meet
are you with me yes
are you sure you're with me
yes we are yes
i said what's the rush he said it's my
culture
grandparents well not grandparents yet
but my parents want a grandson my
granddaughter listen to me you don't
have a child to give your mother
grandchildren by the way i always say
keep your grandparents from your
children
amen
[Music]
they will ruin them
anyway grandparents don't kill me but
we must learn to ask god amen listen to
me doing what's right comes by practice
it does not come automatically
if you want to buy a new suit your first
thought is well i like that suit
it is not well is this for the glory of
god do i look like a child of god in
this suit
or do i look like you know a stepson of
david bowie
what do i look like
are you with me
and so
listen to me carefully if we took these
two steps
we would avoid a multitude of problems
either now or somewhere down the road
because when something is done for the
glory of god god involves himself in it
and makes it his
that's why i say your education should
be for god's glory
then god takes it over
you still have to study god doesn't
study for you
but he takes it over as his project
and you as a manager
listen to uh
ella white again in the book education
page 137 paragraph four what book did i
say
education page 137 paragraph four
have you written that down
okay here's what it says
that which lies at the foundation of
business integrity
and true success
is the recognition of god's ownership
the creator of all things he is the
original proprietor
we are his stewards
all that we have
is a trust from him elder finish it
you're looking at it to be used
according to his direction his direction
page 138 paragraph two
of book education
elder started for us thus our business
or calling are a part of god's great
plan finish it for us and so long
as it is conducted come on in accordance
with his will this is how it ends he
himself
is responsible for the results
[Music]
that's why i'm telling you give your
life to god then your life becomes his
project
give your studies to god and your
studies become god's project the elohim
said he himself becomes responsible for
the results
but the cardinal nature
will have us believe i got this
i can handle this
i can manage no you can't
the only thing the cardinal editor can
manage is a well-planned
catastrophe and so today
at 11 15 or whatever it is
i appeal to you as your older brother in
christ
let us try by practice
to consider god first
and our fellow man after
in everything we do
and i give you this quotation again
historical sketches page 285 paragraph
four writing to young people white
writes every youth should be impressed
with the fact
that he is not his own
that his strength you know
i i count i ask god let me tell you what
i asked god i've never told anyone i'll
tell you don't tell anybody is this
being recorded don't tell anyone
i ask god to keep me young
so i can minister to young people
especially young men
amen
father keep me so that when i see them
they say i can talk to this guy
are you with me he doesn't look like
methuselah he may be but he doesn't look
like him so i should talk to this fella
i ask god for that i really do
i'm in the gym
doing this there trying to look young
so i can minister to young and i do a
lot to young men on the internet they're
right they do all sorts and i love that
i'm so honored
but every youth should be impressed with
the fact
he's not his own
his strength
his time
his talents
belong to god
it should be his chief purpose in life
here come the two things
to glorify god
and to do good to his fellow man yes
in the same paragraph 4 of 285 of
historical sketches you write every
youth every child has a work to do for
the honor of god and for the salvation
of souls that are ready to perish
let me tell you something that works
you give up ownership of your life
and give it to god
what's your life change
let me say it again give up ownership of
your life
give up managerial responsibility for
your life give that to god
and let him employ you to run your life
god will bless your life
amen
reason together
if all christians were cursed who would
want to be a christian
you know when athletes in the united
states listen there's a young boy he
comes out of high school he plays
basketball at college he's thinking what
team can i join he wants to join a team
that has what kind of history
a successful history
you don't want to join a team that has
lost 60 games
out of 50.
are you with me
a history of losing every season you're
losing you're in the cellar that's not
the team you join you want to join a
team that has championship banners and
cops or whatever and
that's what you want now
if christians live blessed lives
people would say wait a minute
there's something going on with these
people
everybody loves a good thing are you
with me everybody loves a good thing i
want to be part of that the young people
are always successful the marriages are
so strong they hardly get sick
what's going on with these people they
glorify god
the young people are not in jail
how is that possible
because in everything they do
they think of god first you know i was
talking to a young person and he was
telling me this is my life
no it's not your life
whether you're young or it is not your
life and i said to him listen brother
if you go out now and run wild and
the other girl praying them
to whom would you take that problem
to the same parents you never listen to
are you following
if you broke into a drug store and stole
some chewing gum or something and the
police caught you where are they coming
to your parents
your life
is not yours
at any age
are you with me
now i'm a preacher i go all over the
world
i've also i don't know the movies but i
said godfather if i ever went to a movie
i'd go to a movie house that's located
in the exploding volcano so no one else
will come
are you with me no one else can see me
it must be an erupting volcano i'll go
to that movie house no one can see me so
i can't influence someone to start going
to movies because i don't want to have
that response it's not my life
if you found out i ran a whorehouse how
many people might leave the church of
the spiritual life just
i thought
as you say
because my life is not my life
are you with me yes yes
you follow the president of the north
england conference
there is a gambler and he was caught in
a casino on south
i mean tuesday is one thing but seventh
easy on the seventh
what happened you start turning your
tithe
you go to the south england country or
the north scotland conference
or the courtney island conference or
something because you're just devastated
your life
is not yours
amen
and so i say to you as i close the book
as a visual symbol of my intention to
stop
the earth
is the lord
and the fullness thereof the world and
they that dwell therein you know in
psalms 50 from verse 10 god says
for every full capital upon a thousand
hill for every beast of the forest is
mine and the cattle
upon a thousand hills i know all the
fowls of the mountains and the wild
beasts of the field are mine
if i were hungry i would not tell thee
for the world is mine and the fullness
thereof my brother my sister young are
all in between you belong to god
and the sooner you acknowledge that
and live by that
the sooner your life will be a blessed
life
the sooner you walk the path of
blessings not curses
the sooner you begin the process of
minimizing the regrets of life
our lives
belong to god
how many will say father thanks for
opening my eyes reminding me of what i
knew i recommit that life to you because
it's yours can i see your right hand do
you mean that say yes or no
let's pray father in the name of let's
stand let's start
dear god
thanks for the reminder
the literal fact
our lives belong to you
at two levels they got
creation
and redemption
father forgive us for theft
for stealing your life
which we call ours
forgive us their god for arrogance for
thinking this is my life i can do
whatever i like so many people are
imprisoned because of that attitude so
many are dead because of that attitude
so many are in rehabilitation programs
because of that attitude so many have
dropped out of school because of that
attitude god cleanse our minds from this
false belief that this is my life
dear god
we commit that life to you
we commit our physical health to you
we commit all the senses we have that
function
we commit our sanity to your god so many
people are in mental institutions
we walk to this building on our own
strength we commit that to you father
help us in all that we do to think will
this glorify god
and how will this benefit others
and father save us at last into a
kingdom with that will be the thinking
of all those who reside there in jesus
name we pray like god's people say amen
and amen
you